the david pakman show subreddit
continues to grow record number of
subscribers posts responses topics etc a
few interesting ones that I noticed this
morning when I took a look at the david
pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT why does liz
warren interview so terribly is the
question her latest interview on TYT she
came across terribly the way she was
answering made it seem as if she was
filibustering and trying to dodge when
she could have easily given clear
concise answers she's shooting herself
in the foot with this yeah i I have
mentioned before that on policy I am
highly aligned with Elizabeth Warren
although I think I'm probably more
aligned with Bernie Sanders um
personally I've met Elizabeth Warren a
couple of times and she was absolutely
delightful but she does not interview
well and we criticized her for when
Genki auger in a previous interview
asked her why if you're so aligned with
Bernie Sanders why did you wait until
after the Democratic primary to say that
you were supporting Hillary Clinton why
didn't you say well I endorsed Bernie
during the primary her answer was a
disaster and this is a problem for
Elizabeth Warren her strength is not
being interviewed and there's also
concerns about how she would do in
debates potentially against Donald Trump
but even more presently or more
proximally in the Democratic primary so
I think that this is an absolute serious
concern about Elizabeth Warren and we'll
see how that develops in the context of
the Democratic primary also from the
David Pakman show subreddit can David
get an interview with Pete Budaj edge
yeah we're trying to do this and as Pat
pointed out and I've pointed out before
we have been trying to get an interview
with Pete Budaj edge who I believe is
the mayor of South Bend Indiana who's
running for the Democratic nomination do
we have a status update pat on what's
going on I know we made contact with
someone from the team and then it seemed
like things really slowed down
no update I've sent about three emails I
guess I'll have to send some more
but yeah I mean we've had Andrew yang on
the show a couple times we've had
Richard O jeddah on the show I think we
should be able to get Pete you to judge
yeah I I want to talk to him and I think
he has an interesting platform he's
certainly not a front-runner or anything
close to it but his his life story is
interesting his platform is interesting
he has issues I disagree with Han it
would be interesting to explore that so
I hope that he will do it and what you
can do to help I guess is to politely
tweet to him and me at D Pakman and say
we've heard that the david pakman show
has invited you I would love to see you
on the show please do it and that can
actually assuming that you're polite
that can help to make some of these
bookings happen so help us out with that
join the discussion on the subreddit
david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t a lot
of really good story suggestions coming
from the subreddit we have moderators
who work to ensure that the discussions
and debates are respectful we avoid
insults and try to prevent trolling but
you know it can sometimes be easier said
than done to actually do that hope to
see you on the subreddit